winning football games what's
the biggest reason when you
look at this team coming
together what is this catching
your eye
I'm trusting the coach Bill
Belichick is one of those guys
he focuses on when he talks
about doing your job it's about
doing the fundamentals of your
job and doing your job right
all the time so now that your
teammate can trust you and
that's what
I see what's happening when he's
talking to them as far as
fundamental football setting the
edge they're doing a great
job of setting the edge when
they double-team a guy they do
a great job of taking them away
earlier in the season they
didn't do that
they had fumbled penalties
Turtles with all these
different things and they
weren't doing their job they
weren't doing the fundamentals
of a football and they weren't
having success now you see those
guys are starting to
trust coach Belichick a lot more
they're starting to do the
little things that it takes and
now they're just out there
playing and having fun playing
football you see Matt Jones you
know and this this is a crazy
thing I have to hold my breath
and I love Mac Jones I have to
hold my breath because
every game it seems like he can
throw three or four
interceptions guys are dropping
it have opportunities to just
not coming down with it he has
to do a better job of
protecting the
yeah I think I think that's the
big thing is that you're seeing
them shorts a treat Mac Jones is
a guy that can go with them
football games as opposed to
somebody who's protecting
football games it's funny ride
it as all this stuff happened
with Notre
Dame I couldn't help myself I
went back last night and
I watch the Rose Bowl from last
year I kind of wanted to see it
from Notre Dame's perspective
going what was Brian Kelly
thinking and then I also wanted
to see it from Mac Jones
perspectives
the hell is this guy ever to
play in the NFL this
immediately Harris and throw the
ball to Devonta Smith he
was already playing in NFL
offense and you already that
essentially an NFL very similar
to Belichick coach and save it
so he's used to the
pressure in the grind up at all
and to watch him go 25 or 30
300 yards for touchdowns in that
game and play perfectly
efficient football it made me
realize the training he had for
this moment and now you're
seeing him pick it up within
that
moment every Belichick team that
I watched just gets better
as the year goes on the way you
think about a rookie
quarterback
I think that the curve just the
curve of how much better this
team is going to get heading
towards February is going to be
scary for the rest of the NFL
and you look at Josh McDaniels
and we can't we can't Overlook
Josh McDaniels in a terrific job
that he's been cuz he's in
Mac Jones here every second he's
talkin to him during
practice to meeting all those
different things I thought he's
done an impressive job
of getting him allowed him to
just play football spread
the ball around getting it to
different Playmakers and
the offensive line have gotten
better they continue to run
the football a pound people to
use play-action pass and every
now
and then you see Josh McDaniels
rip
out a couple trick plays every
single game is terrific and as
much as I love coach Belichick
Josh McDaniels has been doing
a great job with this Young
quarterback
pretty sure has to get your
second take away we're going to
keep it right there in the AFC
really at the top of the AFC
with the Baltimore Ravens team
that continues to win they
wanted some interesting ways to
say the least they've gotten
high they've
come back table and sloppy
they've won this they've won
that but the bottom line is they
continue to win what's
the story right now with
Baltimore they're just a very
resilient
team they are very resilient
team but they're not going to
go very far from our
continues to turn the ball over
too many injuries on offense to
many engines on the defensive
side of the ball for him to
continue to turn the ball over
and now I'm getting to
the point as much as I love
Lamar and I think here in
the next three to four years he
will win a Superbowl but when
he drops back to pass he starts
to give me nervous a little bit
and I like the way the offense
has involved is not just Mark
Andrews in the passing game but
he has
to do a better job of not
turning the ball over you know
his defense stepped up played
tremendous with all these
different injuries but these are
just easy passes I mean you
got to be able to complete these
in the playoffs you won't
get these opportunity
you know you want you would not
be able to throw four
interceptions in the playoffs
and then come back and be able
to win the game because the
teams in the playoffs are there
are a lot better and they're
going to take advantage of
those opportunities
yeah I haven't I haven't been
this nervous like you're saying
watching them are play since his
rookie year there was
moments during his rookie year
was going to 11 drop test but
he had been a lot more efficient
you've been a lot
more effective as a pastor
recently so I haven't really
been used to seeing this one
thing that they were doing and
we knew going into the game and
this was a possibility they were
using Jeremiah
owusu-koramoah who is a safety
linebacker combination plate.
Rover outside linebacker spot in
college at
Notre Dame and now he's in the
NFL and you've really been
the perfect transitional piece
for the NFL game as the NFL
continues to evolve and he's not
really asleep it is not
really linebacker I don't really
think it matters what he
was in incredible spy
for Lamar Jackson it and you
don't really see ever
a Defender matchup athletically
with Lamar and I thought you
saw to that were able to match
up athletically one was Myles
Garrett the other was Jeremiah
owusu-koramoah and it started
to get into the head of Lamar
Jackson I think he was really
lucky to find a way to win this
game
I tell you this and you weren't
you were spot-on with that Joe
Woods who have criticized on
this show I criticize them
a couple times I thought he had
his best game plan he came out
he had seven defensive backs and
I include Jeremiah as a
defensive back because this is a
kid if they wanted him to
play strong safety he could play
for strong safety and
being all pro but he can also
play linebacker but they had
seven defensive back they had a
ton of speed on the field so
anytime
Lamar took off once you got past
two of the most athletic
defensive and you going to ever
see play The National Football
League you had all these guys
warm and you had nothing but
speed I thought this was the
best game plan and Joe would
show
me a different side I don't know
if it was desperation or
whatever but it seemed like it
gave his team a boost
a creative four turnovers so I
expect him to continue with
what these aggressive calls but
I thought he probably called
his best game of
the year
that's a great Point that's a
great point is Baker Mayfield's
healthy on the other end of it
who who knows they've they made
capitalize and some of the
opportunities that defense was
able to create for this offense
but they stopped on some
serious narratives there in
Baltimore this year it's
everybody would say that this
style of offense can't come from
behind and Lamar he can't
come from behind and used the
leave the need to do power
running to be able to keep the
lead run up the score that's
been the case
at all with this team if you
look at the Kansas City game
that's them coming all the way
from behind with Lamar Jackson
you look at the Minnesota game
that's them coming all the way
from behind with Lamar Jackson
This most recent game was just
sloppy
football to go beat the
Cleveland Browns but that
the thing that Lamar Jackson is
doing a little bit of his dirt
dirt hitting these quick passes
you know Hollywood Brown screen
Hollywood Brown 5-yard
turnaround Mark Andrews 5-yard
turn around you're getting some
of these young wideouts
on the outside going and then
that's opening up the power Run
game so when they're coming from
behind if we're it's
almost like Lamar likes to run
around and you know throw some
sidearm passes and get back to
the things he was doing so well
Louisville
it starts to open up make him
feel comfortable in the passing
game and when I watch that
Minnesota went from a few weeks
ago that was what stood out he
starts to get in his element
behind can you start playing
free running around having fun
again
being a big part of that is
Coach Harbaugh every time we
talk to these players and we
asked him about you know why do
you guys play like this why are
you guys are close-knit team
how are you guys able to
overcome they always go back to
Coach Harbaugh Coach Harbaugh
give them Freedom he gets him
Trust and Believe belief and
he's one of those guys that he
always trust remember where this
week this year the first
time and he was like do you want
to do let's go for let's
go for
it like I've never seen anything
like that at
a quarterback being so young and
have question marks about
behind them and things like that
I've never seen it a coat
ask a player what do you want to
do to me that really show me
the nature
of their relationship by Coach
Harbaugh is a cool cool dude
like he's always too I like them
he's fire I've known him
for years but at the end of the
day when you show trust in your
quarterback quarterback like
Lamar special quarterback man
and look at
there's nothing Lamar feels like
he can't do on a football
field but it gives him the
courage to not to be a graph
courage to not to be a graph and
that's one of the reasons
why he threw four interceptions
and that's one of the reasons
because he felt so comfortable
and confident been able to
throw the ball
it didn't work out for me end up
winning the game but I think
he will get better
it's an excellent point because
for somebody to throw three
interceptions in the second
quarter alone in these work
like tip on these were ugly
looking interception and then
it comes back that first drive
of the second half into be
running right it's a third-down
to run
right towards the sideline and
to have the courage to throw
that thing up in the air just
like moon-bog Landmark Andrews
he's over there somewhere we'll
see what happens draw that pass
interference Mark Andrews
happens to catch the football
and then the other one be
scrambling
around his face and he throws
another one to Mark Andrews
that was a touchdown in the Red
Zone you don't make those
throws unless you have that
confidence of your coach you
don't do it you can't do it
unless you have that kind of
confidence in
without those two player that's
a 34%
Jack Jack that's a third and for
when he made that place so
it wasn't like oh let's just be
conservative and get the first
down no let's go for it I got my
best player against one of
your best defenders and I trust
that he I'm
going to throw it up he's going
to come down with and that's
exactly what happened
that's a great Point Let's get
over to the other side of
things with the Cleveland Browns
or heat was coach to
fancy after the game with that
quarterback position and what
maybe down the road here is what
coach had to say
that's frustrating. It is very
frustrating to not score enough
and it's always a combination of
things it's no staying on
the field on third down and try
to run the ball effectively
getting the Red Zone all those
things but we're just not doing
a good enough
job of that starts with me let
me ask you a question why
would we do that
this is a little weird to me
because I don't think people
are asking him about a
quarterback change because make
Baker Mayfield stinks I think
people are asking about
a quarterback change because
Baker's not a hundred percent
and that's the thing that I
question like if
Baker's 70% is Case Keenum does
he give us a better chance of
winning football games at 100%
as opposed to Baker at 70%
because there is a their's
things that Baker can't do on
a football field anymore and it
limits their offense you know
so if
I'm Kevin stefanski it's not
about ego and pride it's about
doing what's right for your team
there's a reason why you
brought Case Keenum because he
knows your system you've
coached him before he's been
around you a long time so you
should get Baker a couple
weeks at least a couple weeks to
rest Jack you said it you
said it look Rodney I see him
he's not the same he's hold his
shoulders he's limping he can't
he just he doesn't look like
a fluid athlete when he's out
there because he's in
paying if I'm Kevin stefanski
I'm giving them couple weeks
it'll clear as mud help his body
physically and maybe it'll
rejuvenate them and then you can
see what you have in Case
Keenum in the future
that's next level it is probably
something that you
should have done a few weeks ago
cuz then who knows now
Baker might be healthy you might
be coming back you know
what I mean it and we got to
give credit to Baker Mayfield
cuz that dude
is tough he is tough to have
that kind of a shoulder injury
that another entry now you got
the heel injury now you got
the knee injury and for him to
continue to want to go play
Cleveland better know what they
have with Baker Mayfield going
out there and got it out if he's
found ways to win these
games but this is something at
this point and I am in complete
agreement with you that's not
only better for Baker Mayfield
it's better for the Cleveland
Browns cuz they have one with
Keenan
before they're put Keenum out
there see if you can steal
a couple of games did Baker
Mayfield back to being and
looking like Baker Mayfield
you're not going to heal that
you know Shield a groin injury
with three days off so what
happened the first time
early on in the game was a
second series of the game The
Baker really tried to hit the
gas pedal and run he pulled up
again you know that he was
limping the rest of the game
and if you can't go do that
bootleg stuff this
the fancy offense is not just a
fancy office and they going to
continue the beat
absolutely and that's why I say
he needs to make a move in
a lot of times people say he
doesn't want to probably Cloud
the relationship between him and
Baker but if I were him
I would go to Baker's they look
I watch you and I
know how tough you are you don't
have to show me your
toughness anymore I'm going to
sit you down for a couple weeks
if I'm going to do what's right
for this team and you'll
because we think about it every
time he comes out and he's
limping he's hurting any fear to
do so much just to go
through a two-hour practice it's
like if you give him time
to relax and just really get
treatment and take his time
he's Bakers are very sharp God
he's going to always still be
in the
meeting rooms he's going to help
Case Keenum he's going to
be on the sideline as a
different set of eyes but
sometimes as a football player
you need rest especially as
a quarterback because nobody
goes through more than a
quarterback
mentally physically and
emotionally you're doing
a football season
yeah in a whole nother element
of this is Kareem hunt coming
back was a big story coming into
this game that they were
going to get this to back option
we know Nick chubb's
a Starbucks then to get Kareem
hunt back and they really
didn't even
give him the football he wasn't
even a part of the game plan
could you believe that watching
this game
I told you I'm like what the
heck are they doing I said you
got to Pro Bowl backs you have a
bag that you can legitimately
line up as a wide receiver as a
playmaker and you're not even
using utilizing a you're not
even putting them
on the field you're not even
putting them on the field with
with Nick Chubb so I really
didn't understand
the play-calling I didn't
understand what you do using
the two two tight-end sets you
not really utilize any of these
guys you can you can bring them
in and you can run a football or
you can spread them out and
you can pass the football with
these guys but they really not
utilizing these guys I don't
know what Kevin stefanski and
maybe he's starting to feel the
heat in the pressure of
everything
that's going on
no I'm sure they're all starting
to feel a little bit
to get to the LA teams right the
LA team to start with
the Chargers right cuz the
Chargers both the teams are
struggling
in LA right now but the Chargers
and Justin Herbert
I think it's
you know it's the team that one
week you go all wow that's
that's the potential Super Bowl
you know they can host one
right there and their home City
and then they're completely
gone the next week so what's
going on with her burn
the charger while
he's feeling the Heat's Justin
Herbert is feeling the pressure
of all the expectations you
think about the rookie year
that he had last year he was
phenomenal last year he came in
and started the first game he
didn't think he was going to
stop and was
out and was absolutely terrific
this year defensive
coordinators have had a chance
to study him a lot more and so
they're doing different things
they're showing them different
look you look at Wink Martindale
with the Baltimore
Ravens Bill Belichick Mike
Zimmer they lost to all those
great defensive coordinators why
because those guys Blitz
them show them different looks
created turnovers doing did
the same thing to Denver taco
dip swamp and Justin Herbert is
starting to feel the pressure
because they said oh we have
a new coach we got the young
stud
and Justin Herbert second year
in the office we can he can
take us to the next level and
he's just not the same
quarterback right now he's
learning a new offense so
checks and adjustments and all
these different things he's
learning on the Fly and it's
going to take time but the one
thing that's been a Saving
Grace and we talked about for
Justin Herbert has been
the fact that he's been able to
run and to use his legs and use
his
athleticism that really helped
them out again still you know
Pittsburgh Steelers when we were
there
yeah you know when you hear Tom
Brady talk and he goes you know
why would I retired now when I
got all the answers to the test
and I have the answers now it's
something you almost got to
remember with young quarterbacks
like he may know
how to beat one defense but
there's always going to be
a second or a third different
look the team's Rabil to give
him and I think you're seeing
some of those secondary or
third just different adjusting
the scheme Sheldon one thing
pre-snap change into this
defense
or just fooling themselves some
weeks it looks amazing other
weeks. So much like you look
awesome in that game against
the Pittsburgh Steelers we were
out there for that Sunday Night
Football game Thursday the
game-winning touchdown down
the sideline and then you just
didn't see any
of that this past weekend so I'm
not giving up I'm not
panicking on Herbert I just
think he is learning that
there's more than one test out
there to pass and he's going to
have to continue to do so you
want to get to your 50
take away right here on the
defensive.
yeah let me make one more point
now Derwin James he's been
excellent form and they have
both said they have a lot of
good young pieces but I never
trust a defense that can stop
the run if you can't line up and
you can't stop of
the Bron when you got to have it
and this is what happens in
January this what happened to
December and January if you
cannot stop the run you can't
you can't go very far in
the playoffs you can't because
it's cold the weather is crazy
and
you have to be able to either
get a first down or you have to
be able to stop somebody from
getting the first down that's
the bottom line and I don't
think they can do it
consistently enough
there you go with that comes
down to defense so this
Defensive Player of the Year
race we've been talkin about
this one all year long on this
show where do you lean right
now as you look at that award
and do some of the stars on
defense are they it's two it's
two guys clear-cut two guys is
Matthew judon who's been
basically everything Levin have
sex he's been tremendous he's
come in and really helped
Propel that team I mean whether
it's the pressures the sax
the leadership you know just
everything that
he does every single day he's
come in he's really made
a difference in the most
athletic God's willing I think
it's in
the NFL Myles Garrett he's just
a freak athlete when he jumped
up and knocked that bought out
some of the things that he's
done
I've never seen on the football
field and he is a big dude 6465
280 lb super athletic and did
you see the way he chased Lamar
Jackson down and call him he is
an absolute freebies are
the two guys in my opinion now
I'm going to
ask you who are your two guys
that you put up there are you
with me or against me
you chose you chose some pretty
good ones right there you show
some pretty good ones like might
Myles Garrett would have
been my number one honestly and
I thought Myles Garrett hit
a lick. Right right yep it is
almost as much as you could
have done
to go try to win that game
against Baltimore he only plays
one position do you know I mean
I have some point you probably
should have put them in that
running back see if he can help
the offense to you version to
play where he where
he looped back around in the
bars went on the sidelines
I mean there's there's a
defensive backs and cornerbacks
and safeties that Lamar
regularly out runs in that
scenario though to see Myles
Garrett who is a step behind be
able to catch up to Lamar
Jackson
and push him out of bounds I
just never seen anything like
that and if you watch the Browns
play all year Myles
Garrett makes those kind of
plays on super athletic running
backs or receivers anybody that
gets in the zone of Myles
Garrett he has a
way of getting on the ground and
then the one where he's
flying 5 feet up in the air like
you mentioned to so he's
doing things that defense then
just should not be able to do
Ian pressures are there 59
pressures on the year at s
the NFL 16 of those sacks got
all these hit her he's at you
look at his numbers Myles
Garrett has the resume right
now to win that award
no doubt no doubt those two guys
are playing fantastic
really anxious to see how they
finish up